now Who am I gonna do is we've got a few
important points on there so to label
them the stationary points are the ones
I'm most interested in okay so down here
based on the graph not based on any
formal argument what kind of stationary
point do I have I have a minimum it's a
minimum turning point okay right there
Adam 3 comma 0 and the other stationary
point is a maximum point head it's at 1
comma 4 ok so far so good just to
indicate you know where that thing is
I've put a massive dollar on it so I do
this ok so this is my gran of Y against
X I said I want to G much we couldn't
compare what's happening with the
derivatives okay
so what I'm gonna do is I know what the
equation of the first derivative is
doing it's there so this I can also draw
okay now it's a cubic I differentiate
and now I'm getting a quadratic okay
what can you what can you tell me about
it good so I'm gonna pop me out this is
why we did this vertically the same
thing right if you have a robot I
actually would grab your ruler and I
want my one on the top graph to
correspond my one on the bottom graph
that's actually very important to me so
I'm gonna do this I beg your pardon
it's a positive pro
that myself I hope so yeah okay I'm
doing this so that I can see that
there's a parallel between the features
that I'm going to read off my my first
review and the features that I see on my
original graph so here at x equals one x
equals one the first derivative has
original so you see that and I can do
the same thing for x equals three
okay that's what you really offer you so
let's get both of those on the picture
okay not so much and we'll make an
argument as for why in a second
that's a great question to ask by the
way
thankfully because it would make it very
hard if we did I'm thankful you don't
need to and once I've got the rest of
this picture on there I'll explain why
well maybe you can
okay now I'm sorry I've got the bits
that I wanted on here
I'm about to draw my parabola through
there I don't I'm not really that
interested in in the scale of this one
vertically versus the scale of this one
and the reason why is because when
you're trying to compute things like oh
what's important about the first three
million what your focus on is when's it
equal to zero like that those are the
important things we can draw some
conclusions okay in other words it's
these points okay for the rest of it I
want to know the sign like is a positive
is a negative that corresponds to
increasing decreasing but I don't need
to know how much it's increasing or how
much is decreasing I just want to know
if it is or isn't so therefore that's
why I said
but one last thing before I actually
draw this on one and three this is a
brother when sir actually does have some
symmetry this graph will have a
stationary point right the derivative
itself has a stationary point ways it
can be it's gonna be it's two halfway in
between because this is going to be
outwards of premise so that's why it's
exactly symmetrical so I don't worry too
much about where it's going to be
vertically but I do want to make sure
because this would be important for my
next step where it is horizontal it okay
so let's draw him draw his travel
okay I've done that but it's enough for
me okay now what kinds of things are
noticing before we move on to our last
rap and make a big comparison there
right
do you remember I've done many many
times and I'll actually like ask you to
do the same I've said okay what can I
tell about this grasp radio just by
looking at it without doing any like
formal computation okay and I said all
right well I like to get out great for
great yet and I'm gonna put them there
I'm gonna map the sign of the grading of
this thing just actually on the graph
okay so if you have hey I'm another
color in some of you school in fact if
you have two colors that make even more
useful what's happening to this thing
where is it increasing where is it
decreasing where is it neither okay well
starting from the left what key tell me
it's increasing right so great for
gradient I've got a politician yup
positive positive positive positive okay
you're right with that I get to the
stationary point so it's zero right
there okay and then what happens because
he turned the sign of the derivative
changes so there are all my negatives
again I hit the stationary point so my
derivative is zero and then off I go
being positive again for all of the real
values left of sorry right on three okay
so have a look at those green science
for a second right do you see that these
great signs positive negative positive
they correspond to the regions that I
passed through here does that make sense
okay look see this here is positive
positive positive positive positive
right and down here I'm negative
negative negative negative negative and
then up here positive positive positive
positive positive so if you really
really careful though because that's add
one more layer and you want to make sure
okay what am i reading what features
Amory of here that result in signs down
here and vice versa okay last step I've
done a first derivative we can do a
second derivative as well and then we're
going to use that guy to
we tell us about this and about this
okay so back to the algebra here is my
first derivative so what's my second
dreams going to bake that's it becomes
6x
let's give me myself good do that okay
now just like with the first derivative
and with the function itself what I'm
most interested in is where are the
zeros the zeros tell me interesting
things right so therefore I'm gonna
factorize this guy and that gives me
this which tells me the zero is at two
which I actually already knew back from
when I drew this because it's a crab
that's got that symmetry right so here's
the zero for the second derivative now
that's just a straight line 6x minus 12
okay and it has that zero at two so
again I'm going to grab my ruler
I noticed that two is here on both my
arm top and bottom graphs and in fact
I'm going to go all the way from the top
graph down to the bottom to where two
should be okay so good you're all around
do that
okay so down here according to all of my
graphs this is where I'm saying to is
equal to and it's just a straight line
there's a positive gradient but because
of my scale a little bit off so all I'm
going to do is just draw my straight
line through there okay so the gradient
is 6 which I would normally draw is very
much sleep but in order to keep it sort
of reasonable I'm just going to draw it
quite flat again remember it's not so
much how positive or negative something
is but whether it is positive or maybe
if that's what really matters to me this
son okay so this is my graph of the
second derivative so that's what the
label on that vertical axis is versus X
and there is the zero for the secondary